During a time when the church
controlled what people could believe
and the kings ruled over what people ought to own,
John Locke, an English doctor, popularized three
ideas that changed society and parenting forever.
First — people keep fighting over their beliefs,
because nobody can actually know which one
is true. To solve this problem everyone
should have freedom of thought and the
right to choose their own religion.
Second — kings can’t just do as they please,
because people have natural rights to liberty,
property, and life, and hence
need to be asked for permission.
Third — parents should avoid
punishing their children,
since the use of emotions to make them
behave well can make them sensationalist.
Instead, they should allow their children to be
guided by thoughts leading them to
become free-thinking rationalists.
This idea laid the foundations
for modern education.
Locke’s ideas on religion and
democracy became the foundation of most
liberal societies, making him the father of
liberalism. His thoughts on education, however,
may have been even more influential.
Locke understood that most people doubt new ideas,
without any other apparent reason than them being
uncommon. However, teaching children how to think
rationally and all for themselves works. Education
is therefore the key to freeing society from
political, and psychological tyranny; and his
book, “Some Thoughts Concerning Education”,
became a parenting guide to that world.
The book was originally written to help
his friends raise their son, Edward,
to become a virtuous adult — the ultimate goal of
education. Locke defined virtue as a combination
of self-denial and rationality — because we
need to control our desires to think clearly.
He proposes 4 main ideas to help Edward:
First, newborn babies’ minds are like
a blank slate - also known as tabula
rasa. All knowledge comes from our perception
which then leaves imprints on that blank slate.
Because a child is highly sensitive to new
experiences, even the smallest association
of ideas can have lasting consequences.
If you let "a foolish maid" convince
Edward that ‘goblins' come out at night,
darkness shall forever frighten the boy,
Locke warns. The idea that thoughts connect to
each other, came to be known as ‘associationism’.
Second, body and mind develop together,
which is why Locke advises to nurture
Edwards' physical needs, as much as his mental
ones. He recommends a plain and simple diet,
such as dry bread, and a small
non-alcoholic beer to make the boy strong.
Rich or spiced foods should be avoided, as they
are too tempting for the boy's delicate mind.
To toughen the young body, abundant
sleep on a hard bed is ideal.
Exposing Edward to harsh conditions such as
cold baths protects him from the common cold.
Third, learning should be pleasant. If children
find academic education exciting and can choose
what they like for themselves, they will
then apply themselves to it industriously.
To learn reading, Locke suggests
games. This self-directed approach
to learning allows the parents to discover
and nurture their child’s natural talents.
Punishment should be avoided, as it can break a
child's spirit and it teaches the wrong values.
To secure the best education, he urges the parents
to hire a tutor rather than send Edward to school.
Fourth, habits always trump rules,
so parents should help their children
establish clear routines and aim to
become role models of rational thinking.
This will help Edward to learn how to control his
desires and think rationally — to become virtuous.
Locke believed that good
habits of thought prevail,
while rules, which speak to the heart, fail.
However, habits are important not
only because they always trump rules,
but because rules consequently lead to
rewards and punishments - sensations
that arouse feelings instead of reason.
To become a free thinker, a rationalist;
a child shouldn't be driven by rules or incentives
but by esteem and fear of disgracing oneself.
Locke's thoughts on education were published in
1694, and became an international bestseller.
Along with Rousseau's “Emile”, his book
became one of the most influential texts on
educational theory and perhaps history's
most important guide to parenting.
John Locke once said that
“Reading furnishes the mind
only with materials of knowledge; it is
thinking that makes what we read ours.”
Since the same is true for videos,
we recommend creating the habit of short
thinking breaks after watching something.
Afterwards, share your thoughts with others and
in the same way, make new ideas forever yours.
Try that right now and tell us
what you think of Locke's ideas!
This and all other Sprouts videos
are licensed under creative commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses, or
to start projects — and today, thousands already
do! To learn how it works, and download this video
without ads or background music, check out
our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education,
visit our Patreon — that’s patreon.com/sprouts.